por favor explíquenos Cómo esta
información tan sensible llega a un
funcionario de bajo Rango
Muchas gracias por la invitación y bueno
vamos directo a la pregunta cómo llega
definitivamente algo falló en el sistema
como oficial Federal le puedo decir que
el primer control que se tiene en cuenta
en todos los sistemas informáticos del
gobierno es justamente el control de
acceso se llama Access control en inglés
y es la consideración número uno cuando
se le conceden privilegios a alguien en
particular en términos de qué tipo de
acceso va a tener lo importante es que
se entienda que el acceso a los
diferentes sistemas informáticos y por
supuesto a los datos asociados a ellos
se basa en un principio que en el
gobierno se conoce o en inglés como Nick
To Know o necesidad de saber
definitivamente la persona que usted
acaba de mencionar y que acaba de
mencionar el secretario de Justicia
tenía o le concedieron acceso basado en
su responsabilidad en el de ese tipo de
datos como alguien de esa edad logró
conseguirlo
yo creo que hubo una falla sistémica una
falla una falla del sistema en términos
de control de acceso etcétera Pero así
es como ocurre de forma
en forma general los controles de
accesos se restringen lo más que se
pueden sin que se conviertan en una
restricción intrusiva porque entonces no
le permitiría al operador El oficial en
este caso hacer su trabajo y cómo
funciona este chat llamado discord todos
los usuarios tienen acceso a lo que se
divulga en esas salas o es una
información que se queda dentro de esa
sala
muy buena pregunta muy buena pregunta yo
creo que es importante conocer primero
que es discord es otra aplicación
similar a WhatsApp similar a viver por
ejemplo por solo mencionar dos de las
más conocidas en las que la comunicación
se establece a través de un sistema de
boeisover it o el sistema sobre el IP no
quiere decir que la comunicación con la
internet se facilita sustantivamente por
la forma en la que la aplicación en sí
funciona Qué se puede hacer en discord
número uno se puede transmitir en vivo
lo mismo que WhatsApp y lo mismo que
Skype tiene otra flexibilidad eso es lo
que la hace diferente Pero bueno se
puede transmitir video en vivo se pueden
transmitir con conversaciones en vivo se
puede transmitir se pueden mandar
fotografías etcétera Para qué se usa
discord no solo para un tema de
comunicación social sino también se
crean salas para responder su preguntas
en que solo miembros de la sala que
tienen permiso a acceder a la misma o al
contenido que se comparten las mismas lo
pueden ver pero también puede ser una
transmisión abierta significa que todas
las personas que en ese momento estén
conectadas en ese canal de discord van a
poder ver el contenido que se está
compartiendo
y se sabe precisamente de cómo Entonces
en este contexto del cual usted me habla
de esta plataforma en particular Cómo
llegó esta información a la prensa
bueno Una vez que se pone en la internet
ya usted sabe ya todo gas récord público
no se puede eliminar categóricamente se
pueden hacer esfuerzos para intentar
eliminar la mayor cantidad posible de la
información que se pueda ver
comprometido pero una vez que algo se
pone en la internet no solo esto sino
cualquier cosa ya es prácticamente
hablando imposible técnicamente de
eliminar completamente así que así llegó
a los medios de comunicación así se
filtró
a los a los canales de televisión a la
prensa escrita así se filtró también a
las redes de comunicación Social es algo
que la plataforma en sí por la forma en
la que opera permite hacerlo de nuevo el
símil más cercano WhatsApp
Víctor noguero para terminar Hay algún
tipo de moderación de vigilancia sobre
la información que se maneja en discord
desafortunadamente
no la forma en la que debería hacerse o
sea discord es un canal no regulado
similar al WhatsApp significa que el y
digo WhatsApp porque eres uno de los más
comunes Así que el contenido que se
publique en la misma no se controla lo
que sí le puedo asegurar es que a nivel
de gobierno
somos extremadamente cuidadosos con el
control del acceso y la información que
se comparte discord desafortunadamente
está aprobada como aplicación para uso
en el gobierno lo que es muy doloroso es
que alguien al que se le haya confiado
este tipo de privilegios en términos de
acceso haya decidido compartir la misma
con todo el mundo hay cuestiones de
seguridad nacional hay cuestiones de
seguridad desde el punto de vista físico
que deberían ser observados